we're not going to look at some
real applications of the k-means
algorithm
and by real application i simply mean
looking at some real data and this is
just to give you a rough idea of what it
can do
and a couple of times i'll i'll give
some editorial content about
like basically how amazing it is it's
what i'll say very simple so we'll see
how that works
okay so the first thing is we're going
to look at a very famous data set
um maybe it's too famous it's the
mnist so
images of handwritten digits so i think
this is from the post office or
something like that
and so there are some examples down here
these are people writing digits they've
been
there's some preliminary processing you
know they kind of got them approximately
straight and they got about the same
size
but you know they're and a human doesn't
have any problem uh
reading these mostly i should add right
you know
um so um okay
so here here are just 25 examples and
you look at them and some are clear
like that that three is pretty clear
that's pretty clearly a zero
i don't know if we can find one that
looks pretty bad i don't know
they're all they all look pretty good to
me okay so
it's a data set um with 60
000 uh handwritten digits uh
image these are images um each image is
28 by 28 pixels and
each entry in that vector so it's a
we represent it's a vector of 28 squared
length and each one gives you the
grayscale intensity
and we'll take it between 0 and 1
because that's sensible
i think the actual one is between 0 and
255 for historical reasons but
we'll take it between 0 and 1. so for
example that
corresponds to a 784 vector and we could
look at it
and by the way zero's black and uh
so that vector if you were to look at it
there'd be a whole lot of entries that
are just zero
right um a few would be one right those
would be the ones
that the whatever whichever the are the
pixels corresponding
to where the white is which is where
it's drawn that would those would be
one so um so you can even imagine in
your head
what those vectors would look like okay
so
that's a very famous uh very very famous
uh
data set um and these are just 25
examples you just get a picture of what
they look like
okay so we're going to run k-means
and this is just an experiment this is
just to be this is just to run k-means
right so what we do
uh is we we take 60 000
vectors each of length or uh i guess
more
correctly i should say dimension 784
and we're going to run k-means on it
and that's it and we're going to ask for
20 different you know partition these
into 20 different
groups now i want to add something about
this before
we get into what actually happens um
i mean you and i know that there's you
know that these are images they're
two-dimensional images
we know what we know what digits are and
things like that um
you know k-means is profoundly stupid
it simply sees a vector of zero numbers
between zero and one which are gray
scale levels
it has no idea what it does has
absolutely no idea what a digit is or
anything like that
okay so that's just going to mention
that okay
so and we run it 20 times with different
uh initial uh initial assignments and
the convergence uh is shown below right
and so
um so here this is just three of them um
i think this red one is the one that
ends up with the worst clustering
objective if we were to blow that up
and the blue one ends up with the best
clustering objective
at least the best that we found uh in
our 20 runs
oh i should add something here this
shows you immediately
that this algorithm is a heuristic right
that we know
on the red run whatever you know here
you end up with an objective and there
is another clustering
with a smaller objective so it failed to
find
the minimum the minimum objective value
clustering right so um it is actually
quite likely that the blue
is also not the minimum the good news
here though is if it's not the minimum
it's awful close okay so we'll we'll
just leave it that way
okay and you can see it it converges in
you know 25 steps or something like that
okay um so here here are the
representatives you find
um now remember this knows absolutely we
certainly did not tell it for each digit
what the digit was like we didn't tell
it
for example oh this this one is an eight
this one's a three this one's a zero
that's a four
we didn't nothing this is just seven you
just get get a vector which
is the image okay and if you take a look
at what pops out
it's kind of stunning like uh like
that's kind of a zero right there
i mean it so most most of the
most of the vectors in that cluster
actually correspond really to zeros
um you know it kind of discovered uh you
know
that that's a one that's a different
kind of one right
um now some of course bleed across
integers right like
that's probably got some fours in it and
some nines um
but it's actually kind of cool like
these are mostly these are probably
mostly fives
um so that that's it
i had sixty thousand vectors and i
clustered them to 20 groups
and you know each one is probably on the
order of 3000
i don't actually know i don't remember
but the point was it clustered them
and then what you're seeing here is
actually the average
of all of the ones in that group and so
they're sort of smoothed out they're
kind of
iconic or archetypes right um anyway
it's very uh
very cool so the only thing the only
takeaway here this actually has no
particular
immediate value obviously is just to say
that here's an algorithm that took in
vectors we did not even tell them that
the vectors
were represented images number one it
has no
knowledge that these are images that's
number one number two
number two not only does it not know
that these are images it has no idea
that these were digits
okay so um you know it's pretty cool
right um and or uh i mean unless you
unless you do read let's say you know
whatever a hindi script
um you would get something similar that
if you if you just took
50 000 or a million pictures of hindi
script
out would come something handwritten out
would come something that were the
character i mean if
if you knew something about it you'd say
oh that's such-and-such that's that but
anyway
i just think it's kind of amazing here
that uh it has actually
quote figured out uh that that there are
these groups of
well here it had 20 but you can see that
uh
you know that it actually kind of
figured out that some of these things
are
are uh some some of these are digits
okay so
um all right so that's very if you're
not impressed by this
then you really aren't quite thinking
about what's happened here
right um yeah so or i'd encourage you to
go look at those vectors
and see if you can say what kind what
digit it is or something like that you
can't that's
that's the hint okay
the next one and this is a real
application now this is called topic
discovery
um well i'll give you an example of it
um very very elementary example but
but you know people do things much you
know much more sophisticated but this is
already kind of sophisticated works like
this
what we did is we took 500 wikipedia
articles
okay i can't remember what they were
maybe the 500 whatever most
visited or whatever they were anyway we
took 500 wikipedia articles
and then we took a dictionary with about
4 500
words 4 400 words whatever something
like that okay
so then we did is you represent each of
those 500 articles
as you represent it as a vector which is
the word count vector word count
histogram
actually right so um
they're going to be a lot of zeros in
those vectors right because
if there's a zero in a vector it means
that that dictionary word did not appear
in that article
and there'll be i mean there are some
obviously there's some words like
the and but that kind of thing
which appear in many articles but
there's like technical terms and stuff
like that that appear only
names uh might appear only in a few okay
so that's it now i should also mention i
just want to emphasize how profoundly
stupid this is right
so people call this a bag of words model
or bag of words method and the reason
it's a bag of word methods because we
take
these aren't wikipedia articles you know
they're written in english
right so there are actually i mean
there's words those words have meaning
they're organized sequentially into
sentences
which are organized into paragraphs and
maybe even
sections so the point is you know we
read them and we understand what it
means and things like that
so this thing is so dumb it destroys
sentences it does there is no sections
there are no paragraphs
and it's simply literal it actually just
tells you
how often words uh from a dictionary of
4 400 different words
how often they appeared that's all it
does so
you could never reconstruct an article
from it or something or you
you definitely could not write i don't
know okay so that's it
i just i all i'm doing is here it's
saying is is saying
how dumb this is right it it's pretty
dumb and you you could
easily imagine nothing good is going to
come on this because
you know it's ridiculous right uh
how how could you partition wikipedia
articles
if you actually do not know the meaning
of words and have like destroyed
the order in which the words appeared in
the document
okay all right that's my preamble all
right
so we're gonna we're gonna run uh we're
gonna go we're gonna
partition into nine uh nine partitions
into nine groups
so we have 500 articles we're gonna
partition them into nine groups
and what we'll do is we'll run k means
20 times with
with 20 different initial assignments
and what we'll do is here's the
convergence
for some of these um there's a couple of
them i think that's the worst one
the blue is the best one and this is
just another one but there's 20 of them
i'm only showing you three
and so the point is we then we take the
best clustering oh by the way notice
that the difference between the best and
the worst
is you know is the difference between
you know 6.9 and
whatever 7.2 right so not a huge big
deal
okay so now we have partitioned 500
articles
into nine uh into nine
groups okay and just and remember how
dumb this is right that that uh k-means
has absolutely
no clue what those words mean nothing
else just it just looked at word counts
and
got 20 groups of vectors there okay
um and we'll see what we'll see what
happened um oh and we also have then
nine representative vectors each of
those
is a vector of dimension 4423
and it's a word count it's like a hist
it's a word count histogram literally it
says
it says here's a representative article
and here's what it looks like
okay so um
let's look at clusters one two three
okay so um what you can do
then is you take let's look at the
cluster representative
so that would be let's look at z one
that's a vector with forty four hundred
you know about four
forty four hundred entries right and we
can look at the largest entry
we could also look at the small oh the
smallest is going to be about zero we're
going to look at the largest entry
the largest few entries to see what's
there and
here's cluster one and here are the five
largest entries in that vector okay
that's it and they're
pretty interesting right um and these
are by the way directly
interpretable 0.038 means you know
basically four percent
so so but the word look at the words
they're super interesting it's
fight win event champion fighter
okay so we recognize these as we're just
being related
okay so you know we do because well we
understand
english and we know what these words
mean and things like that
please remember this algorithm has no
clue what these words mean
not even the slightest for for these are
just
numbers like fight is word number you
know 2173
uh win is word number 1725 i mean i
don't that's
all it knows absolutely nothing else so
it's this is it's
kind of amazing that this is what came
out okay now
for cluster one we could do something
pretty cool so
i mean you already have a rough idea of
what what the things in cluster 1 are
going to be
but what we can do now is we can
actually take we can actually go back to
the
the wikipedia pages and we could say
show us the articles that are closest
to the say for example the cluster one
representative
and here are the titles of the articles
this is in order from the closest
uh to it's i mean it's the first ten or
something like i don't know what it is
okay so they are floyd
mayweather junior kimbo slice rhonda
actually i don't know who i i think
it has to do with boxing so not that i
would know but the point is
uh it kind of makes sense like wow it
actually kind of
figured something out i mean something
emerged right
so that clustering is i i don't know
what this has to do with like boxing or
something okay
fine um let's look at cluster two
cluster two
is uh we go over here and here the
here's here are the words uh
the the most the words that uh have the
highest
value in z2 okay
and they are holiday celebrate festival
celebration calendar
and once again you know
we recognize these as related okay so we
we recognize
but the point is this thing knows
absolutely nothing i mean
so uh okay so it's clear what this is
let's and let's look at the articles
that are closest to that representative
they are halloween guy fawkes night
diwali hanukkah
groundhog day rosh hashanah yom kippur
seventh-day adventist church
i don't know how that got in there
that's fine remembrance day
okay fine um so
it's kind of cool and it makes sense i
mean this makes a lot of sense right um
okay and the third one is uh
it's got united family party present
government so
and then these would be the kind of
things you'd see uh my god sigmund freud
i don't know how sigmund freud got in
there but
okay fine i don't know um you know
frederick douglass okay
christopher columbus fidel castro okay i
don't know jim webb
next to fidel castro okay um okay
so let's look at like uh oh
sorry i should mention one thing um in
this case what we say
is that a topic has been discovered so
we would say that cluster one
is a topic in our corpus of documents
and it has just been discovered using
nothing but
vectors and distance and the k-means
algorithm
that's all it just completely discovered
it just discovered it a topic right
so it's actually kind of cool okay
all right so that's the that this is the
idea there okay
um for the next clusters again they all
kind of make sense right the
the first one clearly has to do with
singers and singing and
things like that uh cluster five has to
do
with sports and it just figured it out
just just figured it out
uh cluster six um
has to do with actually these are tv
series um
which is actually kind of interesting
because we're going to see later that
um it that movies are a separate one
okay so here's left clusters seven
through nine um things like match win
championship
team event you know when cluster knight
is fill million released our character
and then here are the wikipedia pages so
closest to that cluster representative
okay so
so we can do some crazy stuff now for
example we could automatically classify
new wikipedia pages so somebody makes a
new wikipedia page
and suppose let's suppose we stuck with
these nine
these nine topics right because these
are you know it's clearly they're all
topical right
so if we stuck with these nine topics
uh and a new wikipedia page every uh
every day lots of new wikipedia pages
are made right
and so what you do is you simply do the
following um
you calculate you work you you scan the
words count the words you get its
histogram
and then you simply say which of our
nine representatives are you closest to
and we're assigning you to that topic
yeah oh by the way i should say that
when people really do this there's
usually a cluster
associated with i don't know or not any
of the other clusters right it's kind of
like everything else
it's the catch-all cluster um but
nevertheless
and now it's just completely automated
right so that just
just just works this way it would just
kind of go through and stuff like that
so
okay and again i want to say that if
you're not
impressed by this um then you're not
really understanding what it is
my point here is that based on
uh shockingly little uh
about each of these wikipedia articles
in fact all we tell you is
the fraction of times 4 400 words came
up
right so i i just want to i want to say
it again
because it's worth repeating this
algorithm
has no idea what the meaning of these
words are
none zero it has completely
it doesn't understand english it does
not we have destroyed the fact
sentences there's no paragraphs there's
no syntax there is no meaning
and yet it has actually discovered it
has grouped these wikipedia pages into
what we recognize
we do understand all those things and we
recognize that these are reasonable
uh clusterings right so it's actually
very
very interesting what what's happened
here
and in fact it's almost like it's a hint
about
the material of this class is that a lot
of times
stories start with things that are just
ridiculous like
i'm going to simply count the number of
words in documents and i'm going to do
some
something's going to happen like i'm
going to cluster them or i'm going to
make a prediction or something like that
and you'd say oh that is so
unsophisticated you don't even know what
the words mean
how can anything good come from this
right um
and then the answer is the stuff comes
out
um so that's that's kind of a theme of
the class